March 2008 stargazers watched
open-mouthed as a faint light in the sky
blinked into life in less than a minute
later faded away a rare treat for the
stargazers but a stark reminder that our
planet is in the firing line from the
most powerful type of killer star in the
universe a cosmic super weapon known as
a gamma ray burst gamma ray bursts these
cosmic ray guns are the most powerful
the most deadly weapon that the universe
has come up with the Jets of a gamma ray
burst actually don't last very long they
go off in really just a couple of
minutes but in that time the energy
released is equivalent to a hundred
trillion nuclear weapons going off every
second for a hundred billion years
gamma-ray bursts are super high
concentrated beams of high-energy light
and they pack enough punch to reduce
nearby planets to vapor there are kind
of supernovae but it's more like a super
supernova the idea being that instead of
blowing up a star and letting the debris
expand in every direction what if
somehow instead of blowing up in every
direction it blew up in one direction
that it was somehow focusing all of that
material and it was being shot out like
a beam from the explosion site the key
insight here is that we're not talking
about something that's exploding like a
sphere and spreading its energy out in
all direction a gamma-ray burst is
beamed so it's taking all of its energy
but pointing it right at us firing it
directly towards us that's why it's so
powerful the 2008 gamma-ray burst landed
a direct hit on the earth but it had
come from so far away this super weapon
appeared to have lost its punch
astronomers quickly calculated where the
beam had come from and they pinpointed a
location on the far side of the universe
incredibly this cosmic sniper's bullet
had been traveling through space for
seven billion years far longer than the
age of our solar system we're talking
about something that was so energetic
that had you been looking at it with
your naked eye you could see it even
though it was more than seven billion
light-years away
can you imagine something that energetic
something that violent appearing as a
gentle little star going on and off in
the sky think about that for a second
you've got a thing that's so bright that
you could see it by naked eye even
though it's halfway across the
observable universe
you